there's 90s beats and Rhymes were
unmistakable tonight we remember the
life of grammy-winning rapper coolia
welcome everyone to Entertainment
Tonight listen this was a shock when we
heard the news Coolio was just 59 years
old we've got the latest details on
another hip-hop Legend Gone Too Soon
I can't believe in being a star and I'm
only a human
[Music]
I know God is watching over me and you
know I can't I don't have time to to be
a star I got to be a man
1994 on the radio
the dispatch call came in yesterday at 4
pm after Coolio visited a friend's home
in La the lafd tells us paramedics tried
for approximately 45 minutes to
resuscitate the 59 year old his body was
removed just after 9 pm and autopsy and
death investigation is underway no foul
play is suspected
just 10 days before Coolio was on stage
performing in Chicago and earlier this
month he appeared in this Kimmel skit
it's hot out here Jimmy were you looking
good oh my gosh he was so young you know
so young shock and sadness pouring in
from the music and TV World Keenan
Thompson posting weight now Coolio oh
here it goes the artist starred in and
wrote the theme to Kenan and Kel that
song still goes like people playing in
the clubs and they play it everywhere uh
and it says a lot to his lyrics co-star
Kel Mitchell with me today you spoke to
Coolio a few months ago at the end of
the conversation he told me and I just
love the positivity that you always have
and I want you to keep that positivity
he's like a big bro you know since I was
a kid you know and I'm an adult and
still giving uh great advice like he
does and is his lyrics as well of course
Coolio will always be known for
Gangsta's Paradise off the soundtrack to
Michelle Pfeiffer's day Dangerous Minds
you want to tell me what this is all
about a heartbroken Michelle who
appeared in the music video wrote a life
cut entirely too short His Brilliant
song I think was the reason our film saw
so much success 30 years later I still
get chills when I hear it
Julio Gangsta's Paradise
the track won the rapper his only Grammy
in 1996. that year he gave E.T this
Unforgettable moment everything is cool
cool
the always humble musician from Compton
who now leaves behind an ex-wife and 10
children left us with this advice
backstage when you keep it honest then
you be true to yourself and then that
way you can be true to everybody else
I'm true to the game I've seen many come
I've seen many go sometime the Good Die
Young but that's just how I go
[Music]